[phone ringing]
Hey, Dr. McT.
Oh, hey, Dr. Z.
I was just wondering--
which culture do you think
has the coolest-looking gods?
Ooh, that's
a tough question.
I mean, a lot of cultures
imagine that their gods
look pretty similar to us
but with more limbs
and maybe a few
animal parts thrown in.
I mean, who wouldn't want
an extra animal part thrown in?
I would love
to have wings.
That'd be tight.
The tightest.
But, anyway,
I think it comes down
to how those gods
accessorize,
and for me, the gods and
goddesses of Nahua mythology
have always stood out.
I know, right?
The bold colors,
the expressive features,
all those feathers.
The Nahua definitely had
some cool looking gods,
but I think
aesthetics were far
from the only interesting
thing about them.
Oh, for sure.
The Nahua also have
a complicated history
and an even more fascinating
creation mythology.
You know what?
I think we should do
an episode about this.
Word.
[intro music]
If the word "Nahua"
sounds unfamiliar to you,
it's probably because
you're more used to
hearing them referred to
as the Aztec.
The history is complicated,
but the name "Aztec"
was popularized
by a German explorer
in the 1800s
to describe the powerful
Mesoamerican Empire.
It was derived from the word
Aztlan,
which was the name
of the legendary homeland
that the people migrated from
centuries earlier.
But it's probably not
what they would have
called themselves.
Neither Aztec nor Nahua
describe a single group
of people,
but Nahua does describe
the larger community
of independent city-states
who traded with each other,
held overlapping beliefs,
and spoke
the Nahuatl language.
By the time the Spanish
invaded in 1521,
the most powerful of these
groups were the inhabitants
of the empire's
capital city,
Tenochtitlan,
in modern-day Mexico City.
They called themselves
the Mexica,
which is where the word
"Mexico" comes from.
As their influence spread--
not always
through peaceful means--
the Mexica adopted
more than 100 local deities
into their pantheon
while also inserting
their own beliefs and stories.
(Dr. Zarka)
Some legends say the Mexicas
began a pilgrimage
from Aztlán,
or "Northern Location,"
until they were urged
to leave by Huitzilopochtli,
the god of war and sacrifice.
He bid them to leave
their homeland
and travel until
they came to a place
where an eagle devoured
a snake resting on a cactus.
For more than 200 years,
they migrated south
through land much harsher
than the home
they left behind.
Weeds scratched them
as they walked
and rocks bit them
as they slept.
But Huitzilopochtli's guidance
eventually led them
to a small island
in the middle of Lake Texcoco
in the Anáhuac Valley
around 1325.
This and most
of the other stories we know
from Nahua mythology
come from pictographic records
that describe their history,
sacred rituals,
and religious beliefs.
The tlatoani, or chief speaker
of the empire,
was said to own a whole library
of these codices
before most were destroyed
during the conquest.
Luckily, a few were kept safe,
and the surviving Nahua
continued to record
their history
in more codices
for generations afterwards.
(Dr. McTier)
These codices also tell us
that the universe in
Nahua mythology is cyclical,
so that the end of the world
is really
just another beginning.
In the true beginning,
there was nothing
but an endless void
from which the dual-natured god
Ometeotl formed.
You may remember from
our "Gender Fluidity" episode
that Ometeotl
was both male and female,
made of the god Ometecuhtli
and the goddess Omecihautl.
There are several examples
of similar male-female pairs
in Nahua mythology.
In this binary form,
Ometeotl produced
four sons,
Huitzilopochtli,
Quetzalcoatl,
Tezcatlipoca,
and Xipe Totec.
Each of them was associated
with a specific color,
bird,
and cardinal direction.
As Ometeotl retreated
to the highest plane of heaven,
these four gods
created many others,
including the rain god,
Tlaloc.
He and Huitzilopochtli
were the most venerated
among the Mexica,
and the Templo Mayor
in Tenochtitlan
was dedicated to them.
Together, the gods
created and ruled the universe,
which was split
into three vertical regions.
In the middle was the Earth,
made from the body
of the crocodile sea monster
Cipactli.
Thirteen levels of heaven
stretched
above Cipactli's head,
and nine levels of
the underworld stretched below.
The Earth was dark,
so the gods created a sun
to keep it warm and bright.
But making something as powerful
as the sun is no easy feat,
even for a god.
It requires sacrifice,
which is a central theme
in Nahua mythology.
Tezcatlipoca,
a god of night
who was adopted by the Nahua
from the indigenous
Toltec people,
became the sun
of the first creation,
but was a weak,
nocturnal sun
and was overthrown
by his brother, Quetzalcoatl,
a god of wind, life,
and light.
Thus started the next cycle
of the Nahua universe,
the one where the first humans
were made.
But the humans
became corrupt,
and Quetzalcoatl destroyed them
with terrifying hurricanes.
The few humans who survived
escaped to the tops of trees
and became monkeys.
(Dr. McTier)
The next sun,
or cycle of the universe,
was ruled by Tlaloc,
the god of rain and thunder.
It was a prosperous time
until it ended in a barrage
of fiery rain.
In some legends,
Tlaloc sent the fire himself
after Tezcatlipoca
stole his wife away.
In others, it was
the ongoing feud
between Quetzalcoatl
and Tezcatlipoca
that ended the third sun.
The fourth god
to sacrifice themself
was Chalchiuhtlicue,
Tlaloc's sister and
the goddess of running water.
The feuding brothers
struck her down,
and the world ended in a great
flood that collapsed the sky,
and all the people
were turned into fish.
In some stories,
Tezcatlipoca taunts her
until she cries so many tears
that she floods the world.
When it came time
to create the fifth sun,
most of the gods were
understandably hesitant
to sacrifice themselves.
It was Nanahuatzin,
the humble, pustulous one,
who jumped into the fire first.
In doing so,
he created Tonatiuh,
who, in some stories,
ruled over the fifth sun.
Not to be outdone,
Tecciztecatl
jumped in next
and became the moon
to Nanahuatzin's sun.
So that they didn't repeat
their previous mistakes,
the other gods
sacrificed their blood
to Nanahuatzin
to keep him strong.
The world under the fifth sun
needed people,
so Quetzalcoatl descended
to Mictlan, the underworld,
to retrieve the bones
of the first humans.
Mictlantecuhtli, the lord
of this land of the dead,
told Quetzalcoatl
that he could have the bones
only if he traveled
through all of Mictlan
four times
while blowing a conch shell.
But the shell
had no holes in it.
It goes to show
that no matter the culture,
you can't expect
to get anything from a god
without first completing
some impossible task.
Clever Quetzalcoatl
called the worms
to chew holes in the shell
and filled it with bees
so that their buzzing
would make the horn sing.
When Quetzalcoatl
carried the bones up to Earth,
he ground them up
and mixed his blood
with the powder
to make a paste
that was used like Play-Doh
to make people.
The Nahua believed that
they were some of these humans
crafted for the fifth sun
and that this world
would one day end
in a devastating earthquake.
(Dr. Zarka)
Ritual sacrifice of humans,
animals, and food
was central
to Nahua culture--
so important that priests
supposedly sacrificed
20,000 people in one day
to honor the completion
of the Great Temple
in Tenochtitlan.
Some historians say
all these sacrifices
were meant to instill fear
and obedience
in the Nahua city-states
that the Mexica conquered.
But according to mythology
from the codices,
the sacrifices were meant to
empower and appease the gods.
Following the story
of Nanahuatzin's sacrifice,
according to Mexica
state ideology,
even the sun required
the power that blood provided
to rise each day.
In Nahua culture,
like in Norse,
the quality of your afterlife
depended not
on how morally you lived
but on the manner of your death.
Those who died as sacrifices
to the gods
got the honor
of accompanying the sun
as it rose to its midpoint
in the sky
along with warriors
who died in battle.
The souls of women
who died in childbirth
were honored
to accompany the sun
as it set to the west,
where it descended to Mictlan
to make its journey
back to the east.
After four years
of this service,
the souls returned to Earth
as exotic birds--
a nod to the god
Huitzilopochtli
whose name means
"hummingbird of the south."
People who died from drowning
or lightning strikes
spent their afterlives
in Tlalocan,
a paradise
in the lowest level of heaven
ruled by Tlaloc and his
sister-consort Chalchiuhtlicue.
Everyone else spent
their afterlife traveling
through the nine levels
of Mictlan.
For four years, the dead
faced obstacle after obstacle.
They climbed
an obsidian mountain,
braved winds so cold
they cut the skin,
and evaded ferocious beasts
who feasted on human hearts.
Eventually, they reached
the ninth level,
the home of the lord
and lady of death,
where they could finally rest.
But they didn't have to
make the trip alone.
The souls of the dead
were guided by a white dog
named Xolotl,
who, by the way,
is very reminiscent of Zero,
the ghostly dog
in "The Nightmare
Before Christmas."
(Dr. McTier)
The Spanish destroyed
so many vestiges
of Nahua culture,
from documents
to buildings to art,
but they couldn't wipe out
the culture completely.
When Mexico gained
its independence in 1821
after 300 years
of Spanish rule,
its leaders drew inspiration
from Nahua culture
to establish Mexico's
national identity.
You can see signs of this
in murals around Mexico City,
the flag that sports the
legendary snake-chomping eagle
prophesized by
Huitzilopochtli,
and--oh yeah--
the name of the country
that's derived from the name
of the Mexica people.
The culture isn't
just alive in Mexico;
references to Nahua mythology
can be found in graphic novels,
video games,
and other media,
if you know how to spot it.
Nahua culture
is richly complex
with stories
that reflect and explain
the sometimes confusing
duality of nature.
Beyond mythology,
the Nahua had an interesting
political structure,
an impressive
agricultural system,
and two calendars,
yet most people these days
don't even know them
by their real name.
Dr. McT., I know neither of us
got to learn much
about Nahua culture
as school kids,
but I'm pretty excited
we get to now.
Yeah, and I know
those little weirdos
would have loved
all the bloody parts.
Oh, for sure.
[soft music]
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.